ready to go to so we're good good
welcome everybody to another hangout
super excited to be here with you guys
I'm with Julian Marion who runs in
podcast the podcast called the path the
path to unlimited TPT unlimited com I'll
leave it in the description below you
guys can check it out and he said hey
let's do the soon any of you want to
have you on my show you got some
questions asked and said awesome i'm on
board let's turn it into a video to so i
can promote your show to my audience and
we're talking about fighting our
self-imposed limitations and
restrictions and the box would build for
ourselves so welcome and take it away
maybe maybe quick intro for the audience
about what you do and then and then dive
into the questions oh yeah um so I own a
dance and fitness studio alright called
move dance and fitness and I've been in
fitness industry pretty much my whole
life you know play professional
basketball oversee blend raised in
Africa move to Belgium the United States
first language is French some people
think I'm Puerto Rican who knows you
know make so you can never tell ah but
on a dancer for the studio coaching
business and that's what the the podcast
is all about just pushing that message
of whatever you can think of you can
accomplish but you know the people that
are successful truly have user system to
kind of do it they're resourceful
innovative and connected to use their
network and so that's why we have people
like Evan that's done pretty amazing
things and had to fight through
self-imposed limitations and also
limitations the other people most likely
trying to put on him especially in some
of the days hey you nut you know being
on camera what are you doing so things
like that right so that's that's you
know that's for the puck gets all about
and that's why I'm all gone and also
have three kids just in case there we go
all right well so we're probably running
just like you know the podcast guys so
if you have questions you can definitely
pose the questions we can just answer
them towards the end and here we go so
again welcome to the path to unlimited
and today I have Evan Carmichael if you
just go on youtube and type Evan
Carmichael you most likely see who he is
hisa God has all those cool videos with
the yellow signs on the videos about the
top 10 successful for most most of the
successful people that you can think of
right so it's really hard not to find
him so Evan welcome to the path to
unlimited thanks for having me man well
again i'm really excited by this
interview i know that we're supposed to
have it last week but the canadian
weather did not play in our favor but we
are back for this amazing time together
so i really want to kind of dive deep
into you know your story some of the
self imposed limitation that you had and
those other people put on you but
quickly for my audience can you tell us
a little bit more of our you in your
business sure I believe in entrepreneurs
I help entrepreneurs kind of that scale
so i have a popular youtube channel
twitter can't website YouTube spyware
that you found me on there i post daily
videos to help entrepreneurs achieve
greatness unlock their minds fight
there's their self-imposed limiting
beliefs and do something that they feel
they could really make an impact with
awesome so I know you have you have the
the nespresso right and I can't wait for
this one so what is your you know I know
that sometimes an entrepreneur small
business owner you constantly have those
those moments where you kind of drift a
little bit right and you have to refocus
yourself so do you have like a mantra or
go to code it kind of just refocuses you
you know to what you want to accomplish
um I don't know that I have a single
quote I think I think at least for me
what I find is if i look at the same
thing over and over and over and over
again like the same quote uh it loses
its meaning and I like the variety i
like having i loved so the answer versus
series that you talked about is a daily
series that have on my youtube channel
where i have famous entrepreneurs and
actually people from all walks famous
actors and politicians and innovators
and inventors sharing their wisdom and i
find that just surrounded myself with
these people on a daily basis gets me
wanting to do more like I may have done
a lot in some people's eyes but I want
to do more like I'm nowhere close to
what that guy's impact is and he like
pushes me to do a little bit more and so
I find that a lot of them are seeing
similar things to just use different
words and just kind of different ways of
pointing at the same spot and hearing it
again and again and again and different
words from different people help
reinforce the message and helps me want
to push harder to get more done alright
so clarity on a compelling future right
what is your y like you know what you
wake up every morning and do what you do
i get an insane high from helping
entrepreneurs it's a drug man i can't
help it i would do this if I wasn't
getting paid I wasn't getting paid for a
long time uh you know this is we're
doing this on a Thursday this is my
third thing of the day in terms of like
interviews and stuff I have more stuff
lined up tonight it's just like constant
and it gives me energy it's like isn't
that draining if you know man this is
awesome I live for this I can't help but
this is just you know I had my first
session years back where I had this
event with the YMCA where I helped three
entrepreneurs and just leaving that left
me feeling like I have to find a way to
keep doing it's even I'm never making
money I gotta keep doing this I love it
too much and it just it makes me come
alive so every day I wake up and and the
spark usually for me is looking at my
youtube comments because I see people
who have left amazing comments about how
my videos have helped impact their lives
and it makes me just want to do it again
and do it bigger and do it more and
reach more people because I remember
when I was struggling as an entrepreneur
and sucking and having no confidence I
wish that I had this to be able to turn
to and so I'm trying to be that person
for other people that is awesome so are
you an early bird a night owl or an
early al you know it's kind of his kind
of a mixture uh I think my I would
default if I could two nite owl um but I
tend to be I like to spend time with my
wife too and I tend to wake up with her
and so will usually go to bed between 11
and midnight and wake up in the seven
somewhere um so I don't know what you
call that that's not quite an early
morning person yeah it depends right it
depends on where you know where are you
from you know I'll get my most kind of
flow stuff later like everybody's going
to bed I'm in the zone I'll often get
and when I'm when I'm in that zone I
just I work I work I just go through it
because if I go to bed you know that
when you're in the moment of flow you
gotta stay there as long as possible
because you're about to create gold
that's some amazing stuff that's about
to come out right now and so you got to
stay there as much as you can so i might
then you know step till four or five in
the morning then crash them you know
crash out and sleep in the next day um
but in general i stick on a run of
routine okay because i know you have a
clear schedule right you have a very
clear very discipline in terms of when
you pose consistency i think is is is
key to you so do you split your work in
terms of like this is some of the
activities that doing the am though some
of the activities that i would do in a
PM based on my energy level or or not
kind of um i have a specific thing a
routine i guess that i follow in the
morning every day and i find that i need
to set myself up for success every day I
need to surround myself with greatness
every day in the morning because that
that flows that has an exploding effect
on the rest of your day a lot of people
don't have morning routines that are
great that build them up to be amazing
you know built not to be the best
version of themselves right they just
they fall into their day by accident and
so for me starting the day by looking at
the YouTube comments and watching an
espresso video gets me thinking bigger
from there I tend to chunk my days out
so thursday is my public facing day it's
my interviews it's my you know if i'm on
radio or TV or our meetings or phone
calls it's all packed on a thursday
monday is my kind of my new business day
that i took over so i spent a day in
that business tuesday's my writing day
and i find too many people kind of
switch between tasks if i'm writing
and then we did this interview uh one
before the interview I'd be like ah got
this interview in half an hour okay I
can't right now because I'm going to be
you know worried about finishing on time
and then you know that I would be an
interruption to my right and it's hard
to get back into it after so on my
writing day I don't have to you know I
don't shave not that I got info for
shape today I don't think so but uh you
know whatever like I can be my pajamas
all day whatever it's it's I'm just like
total introvert mode don't talk to me
don't interrupt me with anything I need
to get this stuff done Thursday's the
exact opposite is like all I'm doing is
talking to people meeting and and I just
bounced someone to the next and the next
Knicks and I care of the energy like I'm
going to cure the energy from this with
you to the next person I meet is like
coming on boom swinging already in a
high and I find if you can bunch those
similar types of tasks together it makes
you a lot more productive and that flows
the energy from one to the next where I
don't want to be taking like the on fire
hey let's go Julian you know into my
book like I gotta then get back deep
into that introvert mindset to finish it
for me so I have things that I do every
day in the morning and then the rest of
the day depends on what day of the week
it is I do different tasks awesome so
batching right so you do you believe
Harley you know really strongly and
batching your your tasks so that you can
move forward i love it okay so let's
let's move it to you know limitations
right what is your what is your take on
limitations personal limitations in
business or in life i think is the
biggest thing that holds people back i
think it's something that most people
don't talk about or aren't even aware of
you're definitely a part of your
environment and the people around you
and the the the condition thinking that
you've been used to from everything in
your environment every major
breakthrough that I've ever had in my
life has come from breaking through a
limiting personal belief that I've had
and also I guess beliefs of other people
put on me mostly though of my own I
think it depends on how much you like
listen to other people for feedback or
not or how much of your self-worth comes
from other people this as an example my
first company when
I was 19 I had a software company and I
was sucking at the start three hundred
dollars a month you know not able to
survive uh and and the biggest thing
that helped me back there was i thought
i'm 19 i'm selling scientific software I
sucked at science in school which is
true is my worst subject I'm selling to
people who are two to three times my age
you'll never listen to me and I told
myself that story I'm which is
unconscious of it like most of these
beliefs you have our unconscious it's
not something that you actively are
aware of me telling yourself for the
most part they're unconscious uh and it
was until I broke through and realize
that they don't care how old i am they
don't care what i started in school all
they care about is can I help them with
the problem they're facing and it was
yes like I could our software could
actually help them and so that started
open up conversations and started
getting some sales in my business now
one of the biggest limiting beliefs i
had was when brain started approaching
me i remember microsoft was one of my
first clients and i was all happy and
excited when microsoft wants to work
with me and said well who am i to work
with microsoft like I'm one guy
Microsoft has huge budgets and insane
number of teams and what can I offer
microsoft and then i realized after
talking them like oh i think i can offer
a ton i can offer a ton of these guys
and so I think we hold ourselves back a
lot from these projects that we could do
because of the story that we tell
ourselves and the first step is I'm an
awareness of that challenge awareness
that we're holding ourselves back
awareness that we're not kind of blaming
somebody else for why we can't do this
or blaming our circumstances are blaming
our government or the economy or your
education or whatever I because as long
as you tell yourself that story you're
always going to be held where you are so
was it clear like action steps you took
because obviously you you acknowledge
right that okay listen this is me doing
this to me nobody told me that you know
that hey hey kid you you're really young
like what what do you know about this
but it was you so so what did you do to
be able to catch us take yourself out of
that you know self imposed limitation
as a general practice for a good chunk
of my life I've tried to figure out
whenever I feeling uncomfortable to not
just shy away but to try to beat it
somehow and this still happens like you
don't you don't like this is always this
is for almost everybody you always have
linen blazer then you just you just
expand your box right now you're playing
like this box and you're playing this
box and it just keeps growing but you
still have these walls as an example
like I've been doing this for ten plus
years of like thinking about this stuff
but the other week I'm walking I'm
walking to my salsa studio since you
have a salsa studio not a saucy high
density I'm walking I I got beats on
right I'm like I'm like dancing on the
seat and taking the side streets and
then I get close to the main street
right and there's people there so
instead of be like this I mean it's like
let's chill a bit right not doing like
crazy stuff on the street and most of
the time for most people that's just an
instinctive reaction right that's just a
that's what happens you don't even
process that that was a limiting
behavior right like what do I care what
these people think right I'm in my zone
I'm happy I'm grooving and then now I'm
gonna stop because these people are
looking at me I'm not going out of my
way to make them feel bad or like puts
up in their face I'm just trying to be
me and when I realized that this was
like last week two weeks ago I said okay
this is uncomfortable for me I'm going
to do it so then as soon as I had that
thought as soon as I saw myself slowing
down like no turn it up and then I'm
back in like middle of the street just
doing my thing dance in a movie and
they'll the more you practice it the
more you build that muscle of breaking
through those limiting beliefs those
limiting behaviors the easier it is to
catch again the biggest problems
awareness well people don't even know
what's holding them back so as soon as
you can catch it then it's having the
guts to do something about it because if
you don't then you think of then you
live and regret then it's like I wish I
didn't do that right i wish i had the
confidence to do it because in the in
the moment you were too scared to
actually take action on it right and so
awareness and then have the guts to do
something about it even something small
gives you the little bit
strength to do something bigger the next
time in bigger the next time you have a
big thing I talked to all my coaching
client which is what three things you
can do right now to move you closer you
know to whatever the goal that you have
because it doesn't matter have you know
say it's write a book write so many
people have a book inside that's my
belief like you all have a book inside
of you but most people like on that I'm
not a writer like I can't I can't do
this it's like what three steps you can
do maybe it's just write a title open
words put like five words right I just
five words in but the more you take
little action you have the compound if a
that comes in and it moves you you know
closer so let's kind of shift gears in
terms of other people right because we
know you have yeah I think you like to
call it a little man right oh man you
have the little man the little man so
give us a time but trying to be as
descriptive as you can the time where
the little man came in and really trying
to stop you or just you know change who
you are and what I'm tell you I'll tell
you the story of how i came up with a
little man there we go little man is a
real dude is a real dude in my life but
the story the little man is just for you
know context I believe that as
entrepreneurs or someone who's trying to
live an unlimited life you know you're
glad you're you wake up every day you go
to fight for your dream you're trying to
trying to make it happen you're going to
make mistakes you're going to fall down
and a lot of it is in a public arena
right like people are watching you fail
and fall in and suck at stuff and and
you still get up the next day and you go
fight again right that's what you do you
fight for your dream you want to live
with that unlimited life it's not just
handed to you gotta fight for it the
little man is the guy or girl up in the
stadium was just watching was just
laughing you know is like throwing
popcorn at you is like joking to their
friends who's too afraid to get up and
do something themselves to be glad
instead of being a gladiator chasing
their dreams they're just going to crush
everybody else because maybe at some
point back in their life they tried to
do something and it didn't work and so
now they have to bring everybody down
around them and we all have a little man
in our lives and often it's ourselves to
like you are your own little man that's
the self-imposed up the story of my
little man was I was trying to get going
on youtube I was trying to build up my
audience I wanted to have a bigger
impact reach more people
and I collaborated with somebody and I
made a six-minute video and I sent it to
a guy who was in the industry who did a
lot of videos who had a lot of success
um you know way more experience and I
had I you know was just getting started
and he said that no video should be
longer than six minutes long and that
this video will not work and that I
didn't understand how the internet
worked and all of this stuff and like
really like strong language and that I
should not posta saying I should cut it
down and you know I had already learned
i think enough from my past and from
other people kind of injecting on them
on their ideas on me that i know that i
like something if it made me feel
something it's got to have an impact in
other people so you know what this video
moved me I love it I'm proud of it I'm
going to put it up so screw you like I
wouldn't say that in that language but I
don't that safe for your podcast I there
you can eat that haha screws aha
sometime you never know you get on TV
you see that you know then I get screwed
cut tag too I get excited um sometimes a
little man is somebody who who has often
does no experience right like it's your
next-door neighbor who's like who hates
their life until they're going to bring
your life down and those people are
easier to ignore like it might be a
little bit harder than the emotional
side but you could say well that persons
that were done what I want to do so why
should I listen to them right you know
you have a guidance counselor at school
to might be telling you to do something
they've never done it how can you listen
to them or if your parents are saying
you can't do this well have you done it
how do you know what I can and can't do
right if they haven't done it before
then it's a lot easier to shrug off
their opinions but this guy had done it
like he's had success he just did a
different way and so it takes a lot more
guts and courage I think to push away
somebody's opinions who has had success
in that industry um anyway and so the
joke between him and his business
partner where they used to call each
other little man and they're both short
and so like they would call each other
little man
the street and yay little man hey little
man he'll it's like this is perfect i'm
just going to call him I call him Harry
Harry is the little man ok and just
having like the guts I guess for me to
push through and do that and then
realize that he that everybody has this
it's not just me everybody is constantly
fighting these these demons these little
men in their lives who tell them to do
something or not to do something and
like are you living your version of your
life or someone else's version of your
life and once you fully embrace that you
have complete control and this is in
your hands then it gives you the
confidence and freedom to go in actually
chase what you feel is the unlimited
path alright so we talked about fear a
little bit right you say that pretty
much the fear is its kind of the number
one thing that is like stopping people
from from living their dream we're just
like going for what they feel deep
inside they need to produce or create so
besides that time when you're you're a
dance in which I have phones do you have
a time when you're really fearful of
doing something but you did it anyway
and you know yeah yeah I think that's uh
that's the important part because a lot
of people try to avoid being scared and
you're not going to get rid of the fear
it's feeling the fear and doing it
anyway like you said uh lots you know I
have a insane need for people to feel
like uh that that this value in spending
time with me you know like I used to
feel like I can't I don't like letting
people down I hate letting people down
I'm never late for things it's just it
burns me up to let people down and so I
would always fear whenever I had a
speech when I was a meeting somebody for
coffee I would fear that I would let
them down like I wouldn't be good enough
i wouldn't give them information i would
help it's like irrational because every
time i have a meeting or speech is
always off the charts but i would always
fear and so then i would also like
secretly hope that they would cancel on
me you know like hey let's set up a
coffee meeting for a month way yeah no
problem oh come speaking your van or
whatever sure no problem then like the
day out like oh my god maybe i won't do
well maybe you know they're gonna feel
like they wasted their money and i would
i would hope that they would call me and
say Evan you know what we can't do it
today they got the problem great okay
but it's like it's it's self destructive
because this helps
I mission right it doesn't make sense
this is what this is what I want to do I
want to help inspire people I want
people to believe in themselves and
that's gotten a lot better i think just
through practice and awareness like
realizing that this is a stupid thing
that is in my head that I need to crush
to get to where I want to go even
meeting an entrepreneur a meeting a
start-up entrepreneur uh for coffee to
talk about her business I was I would
secretly hope that she would cancel on
me because I didn't want to let her down
with the information even though I like
I come out of it she's super pumped on
fire tons of ideas I gave her a lot of
great things to work with and that's
happened over and over and over again I
still would feel going into it that I
hope that I given up value and and kind
of wood would get nervous before the
meeting and hope that she would cancel
but recognizing that and then practicing
it has helped pretty much limited like
I'm not I'm excited to get on the car
with you do this podcast but I used to
hold me back a lot and I'm glad that I
broke through that I think a lot even
people that I think Tony Roberts was
talking about that how and although he's
been talking you know forever you know
to like audiences of like tens of
thousands sometimes like I mean huge he
still has that right before he goes you
know where his heart is just like he
know pounding it is just like the story
that you tell yourself based on that my
heart is pounding you know you might
tell yourself like okay am I gonna just
like be there just be blank and if it's
his first speech okie note that you do
versus okay my heart is pumping okay I
think I'm ready right i think i'm ready
i'm about to deliver you know second
right did you tell yourself best on
based on the same feeling that you have
so all right so let's go into an action
plan right so i know you you know you
have your mastermind so i will say that
you also a coach the new coach people
right so what would you tell someone um
that is limiting themselves or allowing
other people to limit them right let's
say let's say youtube right because it's
a youtube it is your you know your
expertise right in youtube let's say
will you tell someone is living himself
and getting on youtube and growing
what kind of action plan will you give
them first off I would one hour let them
understand this is normal it's normal
like we all have it everybody is super
scared whether it's get in on YouTube
whether it's doing whatever goal you
have we we don't like to share that we
are vulnerable and that we are afraid of
things you know even to most of our
friends you meet up with your friends
for beer you don't start off by saying
man and I'm really afraid of this
YouTube thing that I have coming up
right you tell you're just talking about
sports are talking about your friends or
whatever so what is normal like this is
okay I went through it I solve other
things I'm working through and so that's
great the next thing is I try to catch
yourself in the moment so whenever
you're feeling so I would try to work
with them like right now okay you're
feeling that right now recognize this
feeling and then let's take some kind of
action step towards attaining it like
what's the worst thing that's going to
happen i had a friend of mine who i took
me a year to get him onto youtube and he
was his biggest thing this who's afraid
with his friends would think on facebook
like if I post this on on YouTube and my
friends see it on Facebook they're gonna
they're gonna make fun of me or you know
they're gonna tell jokes and it's really
your friends are gonna do that you think
they're actually gonna do this or not
but it's like this irrational fear and
so our managed to convince him in one
session that okay we're going to do it I
took at my camera I filmed him he had a
message we put it up on YouTube and then
I connected with his wife and we tagged
all of his friends but watch it and all
of the comments were all great like it
was all really like oh you should keep
doing this good job i can't wait to see
you next video and then that was like
the that broke the belief that expanded
his box thing he's got other boxes other
things that gotta work on but that
expanded his box and I was in posting
regularly for the past six months on
YouTube and so it's one recognizing is
normal to try identify yourself in that
moment of having that anxiety in fear
and then three taking some kind of
action to break through
uh and build some momentum towards
achieving your goal okay I mean I get it
like you want me to go go on youtube and
fight that that fear but you don't get
like I really have limitations like I'm
I'm afraid I'm afraid of seeing my face
on the camera and speaking right so like
I don't know how to do it like I'm
really I'm really afraid oh this is real
this is not fake this is real yeah this
is you your frail usually the person
telling you ok I'll I get your bed good
ok bro well ok so two things why not
think about uh what's the goal that you
want to accomplish right like what is
the what is the impact you want to have
what's your mission what tied into
something bigger right and make that
thing bigger than what's in front of
your face right now like my goal is to
reach a billion entrepreneurs the way
I'm going to do this for youtube so i
have to conquer this thing to help me
get to where I want to go and then that
that helps me move on a side note too
that is try to remember previous times
that I've done it and and hopefully
worked out right I had some success with
it right so if I'm if I'm meeting with
somebody and I'm worried about it well
I've had I've done this a couple times
before and it always was always great so
why am I still afraid of it let's feel
like the recurring things um I'll throw
a curveball at you maybe you shouldn't
you know like if it doesn't support this
big long term thing of yours and it's
just a fear maybe you don't need to work
on it maybe should do something else as
an example I'm afraid of heights right
uh I don't have a need to break that
fear you know I'm okay with not going
bungee jumping or skydiving or you know
going on the edge of the CN Tower and
looking over you know uh I'm sure so you
sure so you wanna countertop in your
kitchen I could do that that's like
that's the max so like is that a
productive fear for me to want to crush
no speaking in front of a stadium of
people yeah like that's gonna be scary
but one that I i need to do because it
helps me accomplish my mission so you
know why do you want to do youtube why
do you want to do
the scary thing that's in funny who
doesn't support some bigger vision as a
support your unlimited path in front of
you or is it just something that
somebody told you to do and you're too
scared to do it and so maybe that path
doesn't actually support you and you
want to go a different way all right
inside notes what I said whenever I
mentioned Evan on his kitchen counter
because there's a video of Evan goof
enough on top of his kitchen counter so
you can go ahead and click find y'all
guys that video alright so just as we
wind down let's go some rapid-fire all
right this is what you know the one
habit or quality responsible for you
know your success right now believing in
myself believe it I can do it believe in
what I'm doing believing it's going to
work out all right what is the one
online resource that makes you unlimited
um this is going to sound really
egotistical i think but my own video is
like I made the videos for me I'm glad
that other people enjoy them and get
value from them but I made them for me I
wish somebody else actually did them
because i need that daily motivation so
it's the videos are selfish creation
than i shared with others what is one
book that you recommend that kind of
changed your life ah the book that i
would probably recommend is out of print
is called radicals and visionaries uh it
was basically what my youtube channel
does but before YouTube it's a success
stories of 30 famous entrepreneurs in
three to four pages and I would we read
a story every morning to help me get
motivating good ideas one that's still
in print the four work week had a huge
impact on me more in terms of
productivity and scheduling and timing
some of the things we talked about
earlier today awesome so Evan if you
were unlimited could not fail I am I am
I on bro I and I'm limited in the next
seven days Evan you ever gonna do it
like so value you can tell you can you
can fell what would you do
uh I don't know man I honestly I'll
throw a curveball out and maybe it's not
anything what you want but I don't
really have like I wish I could do this
you know if I get something in my head I
just start to do it you know I wanted to
build a house before I had the money to
build a house and I just drove by a plot
of land and bought the plot of land and
figured out a way like I don't have I
wish I could be here in five years I
just start doing it maybe that's why you
know we connected and we're attracted to
each other here but if I if I couldn't
fail I wouldn't be doing anything that
like I can't fail right now like I'm
already unlimited things i'm doing i'm
not going to fail that if it's the fail
it's learning i'm moving on like I
already have embodied not failing you
know like and it's a it's an important
mindset to take in to whatever you're
doing right I'm writing a book right now
and it's about the launch to my
publisher I want it to be a business
best seller right I want to be one of
the greatest business books of all time
and and that might seem like egotistical
and like it's not trying to say I'm I'm
this massive genius but it impacts your
mindset when you're going to go write
the book like if I'm sitting down say
i'm going to write one of the greatest
business books of all time you approach
it differently then i'm gonna i'm going
to write my book i have a book in me
right like something you said everybody
has a book in them right like i said i
write my book what's the difference even
a book that does insanely well in just
another book right so you you want to
bring that I think that's a challenge
for all your listeners to you bring the
unlimited path mindset to everything
that you do you already are unlimited
you can't fail now go take action do
something vam there we go you heard it
from Evan Evan Carmichael believe all
right Evan so one party piece of
guidance the best way that you know we
can support you and you know if someone
wants to reach out to you how can they
do that ah that's where to find me is
you know type in heaven carmike on the
Google you'll find my website my Twitter
my youtube whatever method you guys like
best best way to support me is you know
consume the stuff and leave comments
that's what fuels me your comments on
the videos that keeps me going every day
so check it out leave a comment and uh
that's it you'll you'll be doing me a
huge favor awesome I thank you so much
Evan and we'll talk to you soon love it
man thanks all right you have